support your customers you are going to
have some customers who love what you're
doing who love what you're all about and
we'll have ideas on how to make your
product or your service better listen to
them and find ways to work with them to
make it happen here's an example of one
gone wrong ok I use zipcar I'm a new
zipcar user I'm a fan i made a video on
my first sip car experience that you can
find on youtube if you want but i have a
problem with zipcar the problem i have
right now is some guy always parks it
outside of the parking zone and they get
a ticket for it now i love the company i
want to see them do well i don't want to
see them get tickets and pass it on to
the other guy and all i want to find is
is there a way for me to park this thing
properly i walk by the car I see it
outside the parking zone and I get
pissed off that I can't really do
anything about it so the answer from
zipcar is call us we'll make a fake
reservation so you can move the car get
into the right spot to do this this is
this is a crazy process okay I call in
you wait on line you have to wait for an
attendant you have to go through all
these options and the last one is speak
to somebody finally get to speak to
somebody actually even before that
you've got to enter in your information
yet you're entering your your number
your birth date forget what else had
their intern okay then i get somebody on
the line I could ask all that
information again why did I just pop it
into my phone if you can ask me again
then I have to explain where I am and
the car and what I'm trying to do and
they don't understand what I'm trying to
do so I'm sitting here for 15 minutes on
the phone with somebody just so that I
can move the zipcar into the proper
point like move it six feet forward and
it's so frustrating that I don't want to
do it like I'm not going to call them
again the process is broken this is a
great idea to allow your customers to
help you write help the
business but they make it too hard to do
make it easy because your best ideas are
going to come from your customers this
could be a whole new program for them
here's an example of it working I got a
email from one of my youtube viewers
Arturo Arturo watches all my videos hey
Artie row and he said Evan I love your
stuff I want to help translate this into
Spanish I've thought about going
multilingual few times but I don't know
other languages really well he said I
will help do this for you it's a great
idea help me do this but he didn't have
any resources he didn't know what the
process was so we started by created a
different channel and then I help find
software for him that would make it
easier for him to translate and all my
videos now everybody can translate them
if you look in the description of this
video if you like it you can translate
it into another language so other people
can benefit from it that's across all my
videos now and that's thanks to an idea
for Marty row from one of my viewers you
have to embrace this stuff that's where
the real change is going to happen don't
make it difficult for ideas to come from
your customers and start making changes
the idea here is you want to make a
movement you want your customers feeling
like they were involved and they want to
give you great ideas to help move this
thing forward when I think of movements
I think of Martin Luther King and the
human rights movement and Martin Luther
King he then come up with a lot of the
ideas himself you know Rosa Parks
sitting on the bus as that protest he
didn't come up with that idea the the
kids who sat in on cafeterias who
wouldn't serve black people and just SAT
there in a piece of protest he did come
up with that idea but he heard about
these isolated ideas and he gave them
attention and he gave them resources and
he gave them his support and they turned
it into a huge movement one of the most
significant in American history it could
be the same thing for
company so when customers come to you
zipcar and they're trying to help you
become better listen to them give them
resources give them support because
these guys will fuel your movement and
take your company to places that you
only dream or possible believe those are
you watching like the video please give
it a thumbs up below subscribe to the
channel if you liked it and leave a
comment oh and here you have to think
leave a comment below ask a question
I'll make a video response thank you so
much and I'll see you soon